В ефірі «heute journal»
з Крістіаном Зіверсом та Ханною Ціммерман.
Усім доброго вечора!
Якщо уряд звертається до своїх громадян з проханням
зберігати спокій і продовжувати жити нормально,
а також стверджує, що може гарантувати безпеку,
тоді можна припускати, що ситуація
є дуже небезпечною.
Війна нервів: китайський «брязкіт»
зброєю навколо Тайваню продовжується
і досягнув сьогодні нового рівня ескалації.
Китай призупинив серію переговорів з США,
зокрема і щодо захисту клімату.
Ненсі Пелосі, третій політичний діяч у рейтингу США,
чиєму візиту до Тайваню влада Пекіна
прагнула запобігти,
зараз внесена до китайського списку санкцій.
Детальніше про це - Ульф Реллер.
Посеред Пекіна, столиці Китаю,
на величезних екранах, що на стінах споруд,
транслюють відеоролик про могутність китайської армії.
Адже загроза для Тайваню - патріотичний обов'язок.
Багато місцевих жителів не хочуть
говорити про це з іноземцями.
Але вони все-таки мають страх і перед війною,
і перед США.
Я відчуваю, що Америка і Пелосі мають погані наміри.
Сподіваюся, що цей конфлікт можна вирішити
мирно, бо ця війна не потрібна нікому.
Китай випускає ракети, які говорять самі за себе,
запроваджує санкції та літає на бойових
реактивних літаках,
усього 20 км від узбережжя Тайваню.
Але жителі острова зберігають спокій.
Громадяни Тайваню навчилися жити з загрозою.
На телебаченні в новинах показують про
військові навчання та оточення Тайваню.
Проте в закладі «Ачі»
всі продовжують смакувати свою локшину.
Протягом десятиліть Китай загрожував цим людям
примусовим об'єднанням.
Насправді я не хвилююся взагалі.
Мене хвилює лише те,
що вони, ймовірно, нападуть пізніше.
Я не боюся, тому що Китай не наважиться напасти.
Чому?
Адже США нам допомагають.
Такі слова ранять китайських націоналістів.
У соціальних мережах вони виливають свій гнів.
Скаржаться, що влада Пекіну не нападе на Тайвань.
Вони сказали, що хочуть почати війну.
Але вони цього не роблять, це так ганебно.
Возз'єднання - це просто пусті слова.
Нас усіх обманювали, немає ніякого возз'єднання.
Президент Китаю Сі Цзіньпін останні кілька років
створював національну хвилю.
Тому зараз він просто не може здатися слабким
на очах своєї країни.
Він хоче цьому запобігти.
Сіма-Нан - вірний солдат партії та зірка інтернету.
30 млн китайців слідкують за кожним його словом
у соціальних мережах.
Зараз ми знову зустрічаємося з ним.
Питання до нього: чи реакція Китаю недостатня?
Я сподіваюсь, що західні критики
володіють далекоглядністю і
приймають історичні реалії, а саме силу Китаю.
Художник Кейсі Вонг сприймає ці погрози
дуже серйозно.
Він покинув Китай, місто Гонконг.
І сьогодні живе на Тайвані.
На його думку, після Гонконгу Тайвань стає
новою лінією фронту,
щоб захищати свободу.
Він попереджає, що не варто недооцінювати
небезпеку.
Сьогодні ми маємо дві «системи», котрі
поширюються вкрай агресивно.
Одна з них - Росія, інша - Китай.
Ми повинні триматися разом, щоб захиститися.
Інакше вони нас знищать: одного за одним.
Влада Китаю продовжує «купати»
свій народ у патріотизмі.
А армія продовжує свій марш на екранах.
Зараз поспілкуємось з нашими кореспондентами.
Ульф Реллер з Пекіну.
Чи можливо вже оцінити, як далеко може піти Пекін?
На мою думку, для президента Сі на цьому етапі
було б важливо
показати громадянам свої сильні сторони.
Останній рік був досить важким для нього.
Становище економіки погіршилося
через нульову стратегію щодо covid-19.
Він паралізував не тільки економіку, а й країну.
Люди через це постраждали і зляться.
Тепер цей візит Ненсі Пелосі.
Президент чітко висловився стосовно її візиту,
так би мовити, накреслив червону лінію, яку
американцям не дозволено перетинати.
Але вони-таки це зробили.
Це похитнуло авторитет президента.
Через це здійснюються ці загрозливі жести
та відмова від дипломатичних відносин.
Однак я не думаю, що він допустить,
щоб дійшло до крайності.
Адже він не зацікавлений у військовому конфлікті
з Америкою, наразі йому бракує сил.
Але все іде до того, що відносини між країнами
будуть дуже холодними.
Запитання до Ельмара Тевесена з Вашингтону:
Якими будуть конкретні наслідки для США та світу
унаслідок припинення кліматичних
переговорів з Китаєм?
Обидві сторони, як не дивно, погодилися
на кліматичному саміті в Глазго,
що вони спільно прагнуть скоротити, наприклад,
використання метану.
Було створено робочу групу для
спільної розробки та обміну технологіями.
Невідомо, чи це лише тимчасове
припинення переговорів,
чи Китай хоче повністю розірвати угоди.
Це було б погано для всього світу.
Тільки, якщо США і Китай об'єднаються, це
мотивуватиме інших теж приєднатися.
Саме це Вашингтон намагається донести до Пекіну:
що шкода набагато більша, ніж доречність
хвилювання щодо візиту до Тайваню.
З погляду США, яка небезпека того,
що щось виходить з-під контролю,
якщо брати до уваги те, що Китай маневрує зброєю?
Це небезпечно на всіх рівнях.
Зазвичай ведуться переговори між командирами
в Пентагоні і Міністерством оборони Китаю.
Саме там вони обговорюють подальші дії:
які маневри мають намір проводити,
як зменшити занепокоєння та ризики.
Але не цього разу. І це може мати погані наслідки,
надто ж цього разу.
Тепер у повітрі пілоти винищувачів з обох сторін:
американські і китайські. Цілком реально,
що в одного з них
може скластися хибне відчуття, що на
нього нападають і реакція може бути
дуже бурхливою і мати жахливі наслідки.
Врахуємо також те, що командири
також не мають чітких вказівок.
Ульфе Реллере, як Китай ставиться до Німеччини?
Адже нещодавно Комітет з прав людини
парламенту Німеччини оголосив про візит
до Тайваню наприкінці жовтня.
Власне, ставлення до Німеччини є досить позитивним.
Коли ми кажемо, знімаючи репортаж,
що ми родом з Німеччини,
найчастіше це відчиняє перед нами будь-які двері.
Китайці люблять німецьку продукцію.
Китайський уряд також не починав жодних кампаній
щодо Німеччини.
Так, як він це зробив, наприклад, щодо Америки.
Те, що критика з боку Німеччини щодо порушення
прав людини чи відносин з Росією стає гучнішою,
завжди спричиняє посилену критику
з боку китайського уряду.
Особливо такі поїздки, які оголосила Німеччина:
це страх президента Сі, що через часті
поїздки інші держави вибудують дипломатичні
відносини з Тайванем.
Для запобігання він робить те, що Китай робить завжди:
залякує за допомогою економіки.
Що стосується Німеччини, то це означає одне:
не слід вмішуватися в цей конфлікт, якщо Німеччина
боїться холодної зими через брак російського газу.
Це найсильніший аргумент.
І через це надалі відносини між Німеччиною та Китаєм
можуть стати «замороженими» в майбутньому.
До Німеччини. Сьогодні ця країна відома
у всьому світі
через виконання будівельнихпроєктів,
надзвичайно довго за часом і
шалено дорого за витратами.
І лише в тому разі, якщо проєкт таки завершать.
Встановлення терміналів для рідкого природного газу
та під'єднання його до мережі.
Такий проєкт триває до 8 років, якщо все піде добре.
Але Німеччина не має 8 років,
щоб впоратися з неминучою енергетичною кризою.
Тому уряд Німеччини і уряд землі Нижня Саксонія
наголошує:
терміни виконання - 10 місяців.
І підготовча робота офіційно розпочалася,
хоча багато питань досі залишаються відкритими.
Репортаж Елізабет Шмідт із Вільгельмсгафена.
Франц-Йозеф Кіссінг дуже добре пам'ятає,
коли надійшов дзвінок із Федерального міністерства
економіки.
Це було 8 березня,
через два тижні після нападу Росії на Україну.
Чи зможете ви побудувати газопровід
у районі Вільгельмсгафена до кінця року?
Про це попросили його компанію.
Це був напружений тиждень.
Це зайняло лише 7 днів -
від першого дзвінка керівництва до складання плану
та перевірки, чи це можливо реалізувати.
Це спрацювало й тепер ми втілюємо це в життя.
Офіційного дозволу на будівництво ще не видано.
Його видадуть протягом двох тижнів,
сподівається компанія Kißing.
Проте треба бути готовими.
Сотні тисяч тонн піску та щебеню скидаються на поля
та луки,
будівельна дорога вже може бути засипана.
Це боротьба з часом,
погодою та проблемами доставки.
Нам довелося зіткнутися з неплатоспроможністю
компанії,
яка завжди робила важливі для нас компоненти.
То були великі перешкоди.
Крім того, підтримка з боку людей у ​​цьому проєкті,
з боку влади та політики
була чудовою.
У Німеччині ми розуміємо це інакше.
22 грудня 1500 масивних сталевих труб
вагою дев'ять тонн кожна, виготовлених у Зальцгіттері,
будуть закопані в землю та утворять
26-кілометровий газопровід.
Якщо все піде за планом,
трубопровід з'єднає плавучий термінал зрідженого газу
у Вільгельмсгафені з газовою мережею.
Потім танкери доставлять ЗПГ на термінал.
Тільки один цей причал може замінити 20% постачання
російського природного газу на рік.
Це могло статися набагато раніше.
Ми надто довго чекали,
ми запланували цей проєкт ще 2019 року.
На той час він також провалився﻿ через опір у регіоні,
бо лунала така думка:
«Для чого, у нас є ж російський газ?
Незважаючи на анексію Криму та на те,
що нам слід бути набагато розумнішими в цьому
питанні,
ми не надто від них залежні».
Інші країни просунулися набагато далі
у цьому напрямку.
В Іспанії вже є шість терміналів зрідженого газу
і будується сьомий.
У жодній іншій країні ЄС немає такої кількості.
Іспанія вже не залежить від російських поставок.
Тепер Німеччина має надолужити.
У районі Вільгельмсгафена 130 сторін, власників та
фермерів,
мали дати згоду на будівництво газопроводу.
Дехто отримає великі компенсаційні виплати.
У травні уряд Німеччини провів закон про прискорення
виробництва ЗПГ.
Це підірвало оцінку впливу на довкілля.
У захисників природи був лише один тиждень,
щоб заперечити.
Байдуже, але не всім.
Довелося прочитати 400-сторінковий екологічний звіт,
а також безліч інших експертних висновків та
картографічних матеріалів.
Тому розумна співпраця неможлива.
Загалом це означає, що десятиліття позитивного
розвитку
в галузі природи та екологічного права
в Німеччині та Європі перекреслюються.
Тут у затоці плавають морські свинки, що суворо
охороняються,
гніздяться шість видів птахів, що перебувають під
загрозою зникнення.
Будівельник трубопроводу компанія Kißing
обіцяє найкращий захист для тварин та рослин.
Але енергопостачання населення, за його словами,
зараз стоїть на першому місці.
А на сайті zdfheute.de ви знайдете тематичний блок
«енергетична криза»,
разом із графіком рівня заповнення газових сховищ
та поточного використання трубопроводів.
А тепер огляд подальших новин, Ханно.
Президент Росії Путін та
президент Туреччини Ердоган
зустрілися вдруге за кілька тижнів.
Сьогодні в Сочі.
За даними Кремля, вони домовилися, зокрема,
про тіснішу економічну співпрацю.
А Туреччина заявила,
що у майбутньому платитиме за російський газ у рублях.
Війна в Україні також одна з тем:
Путін подякував турецьким посередникам
за роботу над зерновою угодою між Росією та Україною.
Сьогодні вранці ще три зерновози
залишили українські порти.
З боку Amnesty International пролунала критика
щодо військової тактики української армії,
яка, за словами організації, загрожує цивільному
населенню.
Президент Зеленський різко відреагував на
слова правозахисної організації.
Організація хоче перекласти відповідальність
з агресора на жертву, вважає Зеленський.
Правозахисна організація у своїй доповіді звинуватила
Україну в тому,
що вона наражає населення на небезпеку,
розміщуючи війська в житлових районах.
Ізраїльські війська вбили
військового керівника екстремістської палестинської
організації
«Ісламський джихад».
Внаслідок кількох ізраїльських авіаударів
загинуло щонайменше десять людей
і понад 50 людей було поранено, повідомляють
палестинські джерела.
Згідно з ізраїльськими джерелами, атаки були
спрямовані на військові бази
та членів «Ісламського джихаду»,
які, ймовірно, готували напади на Ізраїль.
Увечері було оголошено про вжиті у відповідь заходи:
із Сектора Газа в бік Ізраїлю були випущені ракети,
які були перехоплені.
Кельнська архієпархія отримала позов
від жертви насильства на суму 725 000 євро.
За словами адвоката позивача,
це перший подібний позов проти церкви як інституту
у Німеччині.
63-річний позивач сотні разів зазнавав насильства
з боку священика,
будучи вівтарником у 1970-х роках.
Нині покійний священик зізнався у скоєному.
З 2014 року йому більше не дозволялося виконувати
свої обов'язки.
Хоча пожежа в берлінському лісі Ґрюневальд
вже здебільшого локалізована, місце займання
створює проблеми для аварійних служб.
За даними поліції, земля розпечена до 700 градусів
і є небезпека нових загорянь.
За допомогою доставленої техніки
сили екстреної допомоги
змогли отримати відомості про ситуацію, що наразі
склалася.
Територія охолоджується водою.
Якою людиною треба бути,
щоб на довгі роки перетворити життя на пекло для
батьків,
які втратили свою дитину внаслідок масового вбивства
у школі?
Стверджуючи, всупереч своєму здоровому глузду,
що ﻿все це було інсценуванням.
До таких людей належить Алекс Джонс.
Він є дуже впливовим в радикальних правих колах США,
він заробив на цьому мільйони.
Тепер він зізнався в суді, що його брехня була помилкою,
що найстрашніше в історії США масове вбивство
у початковій школі в Коннектикуті
було на 100% реальним.
Алекс Джонс повинен виплатити батькам у скорботі
4,1 мільйона доларів відшкодування моральної шкоди.
І це лише початок.
Це може стати найефективнішим засобом проти тих,
хто творить гроші та політику на вигаданих історіях
про змови.
Мій син справді жив, я справжня мама.
Скарлет Льюїс ніколи не думала,
що їй доведеться переконувати когось у цих простих
істинах.
Але Алекс Джонс не цікавиться істиною,
а переконанням інших людей.
Він стверджував, що різні в школі «Сенді Гук»
із 20 загиблими дітьми ﻿ніколи не було.
Це все, мовляв, було інсценуванням, а батьки
були акторами.
Таємна урядова змова з метою
відібрати в американців вогнепальну зброю.
Те, що батько тримав на руках свого застреленого сина,
було, мовляв, брехнею.
Мені бракує слів,
щоб описати, яким пеклом були для мене останні роки.
Що мені та іншим довелося пережити
через недбалість та нерозсудливість Алекса Джонса.
У суді він виглядав приголомшеним через те, що,
очевидно,
перебуває в місці, де є різниця між тим, чи ти
обманюєш чи говориш правду.
Суддя вказала на те,
що він перебуває під присягою і що це не
шоу з його виступом.
Під час перехресного допиту адвокат жертви кинув
бомбу.
12 днів тому ваші адвокати допустили помилку.
Вони надіслали мені цифрову копію всіх текстових
повідомлень,
надісланих із вашого телефону за останні два роки.
Тоді Алекс Джонс зрозумів, що у нього проблеми.
Тому що ці повідомлення також доводять,
що він сказав неправду під присягою у суді.
Фанати Джонса роками погрожували і переслідували
батьків загиблих дітей.
Тепер йому довелося зніяковіло визнати:
Я вірю, що подія в Сенді Гук дійсно сталася,
це жахлива подія.
Але Алекс Джонс продовжує свою підривну діяльність.
Йдеться про коронавірус чи брехню,
що Дональд Трамп виграв останні вибори,
Алекс Джонс у цьому задіяний
і заробляє десятки мільйонів.
Він рекламує фанатську атрибутику і каже,
що гроші потрібні йому зараз більше, ніж будь-коли.
Тепер він заявив про банкрутство.
Таким чином йому вдалося домогтися того,
що подальший розгляд проти нього був відкладений
на якийсь час.
Проте захисник жертв сподівається,
що штраф у мільйон доларів може стати сигналом.
Якщо повідомлення дійде до різних ЗМІ всього світу,
не тільки Алекса Джонса, то це буде повідомлення:
ви не можете так чинити з приватними особами.
Перетворювати їхнє життя на пекло і навмисно
поширювати брехню,
яка служить вашим цілям.
І, ймовірно, це не останні мільйони штрафу,
які Джонсу доведеться виплатити.
Але це ніяк не впливає на нього.
Навіть сьогодні він присягається ніколи не зупинятися.
Я ніколи не здаюся, я ніколи не зупиняюся.
Він не хоче здаватися. Чи всі, хто вірили у те,
що поширював ведучий конспірологічного шоу,
знову замислилися, адже їхній кумир
сам зізнався у тому, що брехав?
Хотілося б сподіватись, що так.
П'ятий за величиною експортер нафти у світі
змушений купувати третину бензину у сусідньої країни.
Електромережі виходять з ладу влітку
за температури, що сягає 50°С.
Доходи від продажу нафти зростають як ніколи,
а частина населення виживає лише
завдяки продовольчій допомозі.
Усе це свідчить про те, що в країні величезна корупція,
що багато речей йдуть не за планом.
Нині в Іраку немає уряду,
а в країні панує справжня національна та економічна криза
і посилюється страх перед новою громадянською війною.
Докладніше - Брігітте Заар і Камран Зафіаріан.
Карім - безробітний вчитель.
Він проїхав понад 200 км з другом,
щоб відвідати п'ятничну молитву
в урядовому кварталі Багдада.
Сьогодні тут зібралися сотні тисяч іракців,
в нестерпну спеку.
Для Каріма та всіх інших
п'ятнична молитва також має політичне підґрунтя.
Сьогодні я тут заради всіх іракців,
усіх тих, хто не має роботи.
В нашій країні вже багато років нічого не змінюється.
Він - надія Каріма та мільйонів іракців -
Муктада аль-Садр,
впливовий шиїтський
мусульманський священнослужитель.
Він переміг на виборах у жовтні 2021 року
шиїтську коаліцію «Держава закону»,
яку очолював експрем'єр-міністр Нурі аль-Малікі.
Але жодна політична група
не змогла сформувати уряд.
Поки прибічники аль-Малікі, коаліція якого
програла на виборах, борються за владу,
аль-Садр закликає своїх послідовників
штурмувати парламент.
Послідовники аль-Садра хочуть
завадити старій політичній еліті
знову захопити владу.
Вони досі продовжують утримувати під контролем
будівлю парламенту Іраку.
А сам аль-Садр вимагає нового радикального початку
та погрожує своїм опонентам.
Для них більше не буде місця.
Якщо на те є Божа воля, це мирна революція
у рамах демократичного процесу.
Спершу треба розпустити парламент,
потім - провести нові вибори.
Ірак уже майже рік переживає політичну кризу.
Чверть із 42 млн жителів Іраку живуть
за межею бідності.
Він хоче це змінити.
Муктада аль-Садр - син відомих в Іраку вчених.
Його вважають націоналістом, поборником простих людей.
За ним слідують мільйони людей з ​​усієї країни
та десятки тисяч бійців шиїтського ополчення,
які вже воювали проти американських військ в Іраку.
За що бореться аль-Садр?
Він хоче правити Іраком
та хоче зменшити вплив Ірану в країні.
Основною цілю його політичної програми,
що також може збільшити кількість його послідовників,
є боротьба з корупцією.
Ірак став однією з найкорумпованіших країн світу
після вторгнення США 2003 року.
Сам Садр також причетний до цієї корупції.
Зараз в Іраку назріває запекла боротьба за владу
між шиїтськими політичними групами.
Обидві мають тисячі озброєних послідовників.
Послідовники аль-Садра -
іракські націоналісти з дуже радикальними поглядами,
які борються проти проіранських прибічників
експрем'єр-міністра аль-Малікі.
І те, що шиїти, які раніше неодноразово зазнавали утисків,
не можуть знайти спільну мову,
свідчить про те, наскільки сильно роздробленою є
політична система країни,
і показує, як важко буде наступними роками
створити в Іраку хоча б більш-менш стабільну систему.
Демонстранти досі не покинули будівлю парламенту.
Громадянська війна мала б фатальні наслідки,
адже стабільність усього регіону залежить
від стабільності в Іраку.
Чинний прем'єр-міністр
закликав до спокою та стриманості, але марно.
Свідки подій кажуть, що його найбільшим досягненням
може бути те,
що він пережив своє перебування на посаді.
А тепер - знову новини від Ханни.
Розпочну з теми, неабияк актуальної
для споживачів та промисловості -
можливе введення додаткової оплати за газ.
Принаймні це планує уряд Німеччини.
І це, ймовірно, почне спустошувати наші гаманці
вже з осені.
Зараз вивчають питання щодо того,
чи можна додаткову оплату за газ не обкладати
податком на додану вартість.
Штефані Барретт на зв'язку з Франкфурта.
Як ми маємо це розуміти?
Це можна досить легко обчислити.
Додаткова оплата за газ мала б обкладатися 19% ПДВ.
Міністр фінансів Німеччини Крістіан Лінднер
хоче уникнути цього обкладання податком
і вивчає всі можливі способи.
Згідно із законодавством ЄС
енергоносії обкладаються ПДВ,
тому уряд Німеччини має знайти законний спосіб
уникнути обкладання ПДВ додаткової оплати за газ.
За повідомленнями, розмір оплати
може становити від 1,5 до 5 центів за кВт⋅год.
Розмір оплати залежатиме від того,
як змінюватимуться ціни на газ,
і насамперед від того, які обсяги доведеться
закуповувати в інших постачальників.
Точну суму мають повідомити до середини серпня.
Для сім'ї з двох осіб сума може становити
від 214 до 714 євро на рік.
Хоч і додаткова оплата за газ
з'явиться в рахунках лише в листопаді чи в грудні,
це навряд чи покращує наше становище.
Додаткова оплата значно вплине на фінансове становище
споживачів та підприємств,
що сьогодні також спричинило критику.
Що саме критикували?
Так, промисловість критикує те,
що фінансовий тягар розподіляється досить нерівномірно.
90% додаткової оплати
перекладають на споживачів та підприємства,
а 10% - на постачальників енергії.
Промисловість вважає, що необхідно поліпшити цей проєкт,
аби захистити не лише споживачів
від надвисоких рахунків, а й підприємства.
Попри все, сьогодні є й позитивні новини
з енергетичного фронту:
газові сховища заповнені вже майже на 75%,
а до першого вересня мають бути
заповнені не менш ніж на 75%.
Німецький фондовий індекс DAX
сьогодні знизився,
але загалом за тиждень усе ж дещо зріс.
Дякую за огляд, Штефані.
М'яч знову в грі.
Новий сезон Бундесліги розпочався сьогодні
матчем франкфуртського клубу «Айнтрахт»
проти мюнхенської «Баварії».
Декілька хвилин тому матч завершився.
«Баварія» перемогла з рахунком 6:1.
Метеорологічна служба Німеччини попереджає
про сильні грози зі зливами, шквалами та градом
у районах Баден-Вюртембергу та Баварії.
Південна Корея вперше запустила в космос
власний місячний зонд.
Ракета «Falcon 9»
аерокосмічного приватного підприємства «SpaceX»
вивела у космос орбітальний зонд «Данурі».
Очікується, що зонд прибуде на Місяць в середині грудня.
Потім «Данурі» має дослідити Місяць,
зібрати дані та знайти місце для посадки ровера,
оскільки це одна з цілей космічної місії Південної Кореї.
Такими були новини з Землі цієї п'ятниці.
Дякуємо за те, що залишаєтеся з нами.
Приблизно о 23:45 очікуйте на «heute journal up:date»
з Крістофером Верманом.
Гарного вечора. До побачення.
Ласкаво просимо до перегляду прогнозу погоди.
Сьогодні трохи дощило через холодний фронт,
складової циклону над Скандинавією.
Холодний фронт переміщується на південний схід Німеччини,
тягнеться вздовж Альп.
Однак за ним вже йде антициклон.
Але ми повертаємося до холодного фронту,
який уже пройшов над країною сьогодні по обіді,
через що в Куксгафені температура сягла 19°С,
а в Реґенсбурзі, якого не досяг фронт,
було дуже спекотно - 36°С.
І через різницю температур на південному сході
подекуди йдуть сильні грози.
Така погода буде і вночі.
Від Берліна, Бранденбурга аж до Альп
пройдуть зливи та грози.
Штормові попередження в районі Дунаю та південніше.
Очікуються град, шквали та зливи,
які можуть тривати кілька годин,
тож попереджають про ймовірність виникнення повеней.
Вночі похолоднішає:
8°С - у регіонах з ясною погодою,
18°С - у регіонах, де йтимуть грози.
Завтра не буде такої помітної різниці температур:
на узбережжі - 19°С, в регіоні навколо Рейну - 27°С.
Крім того, завтра очікується спокійніша погода.
Південніше Дунаю - сильна хмарність,
але зливи та грози йтимуть лише подекуди.
В інших регіонах сонячно, невелика хмарність.
Вплив високого тиску відчуватиметься
і впродовж наступних кількох днів.
Але це також означає, що навряд чи випаде
бодай одна крапля дощу.
Очікується сонячна погода, подекуди хмарно.
Загалом буде не так спекотно,
температура коливатиметься від 20 до 32°С.
Ось і все від нас. Гарного вам вечора.